shell est donc un bon jour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
le chef donne comme assise turc
multipliant les visites entre reaper en
libye deux visites en trois mois
notamment à tripoli où il a rencontré le
leader du gène a failli zèle saint
georges
c'est un moyen de réaffirmer le soutien
de la turquie à la libye aux ogm
c'est plus que ça madame la visite
permanente de ministre de la défense et
du milieu affaires étrangères turc à
tripoli ou à misrata démontre simplement
que la turquie considère comme il ne
cesse de le clamer d'ailleurs
officiellement la tripolitaine la libye
en général mais la tripolitaine puisque
pour l'instant et ne contrôle que la
tripolitaine comme sa colonie on n'est
plus dans retour dans retour vers le
futur on aide en retour dans le passé
allez monsieur erdogan considère qu'il
doit étendant son prétendu empire alors
qu'il a de grosses difficultés dans son
pays après la guerre aux kurdes en syrie
il va maintenant tenter d'occuper
l'ensemble de la libye au nez à la barbe
des européens et des occidentaux et je
regrette qu'en la matière il trouve la
complicité de l'italie 1 il faut que
l'italie nous dise si elle est dans
l'union européenne avec l'union
européenne ou avec la turquie puisque le
ministre de la défense italien s'est
rendu à tripoli et que depuis le début
du conflit de l offensive que monsieur
haftar a lancé contre tripoli et la
prise de contrôle des deux tiers du pays
par monsieur haftar l'italie a toujours
joué double jeu pour protéger ses
intérêts pétroliers de l'est ni elle a
toujours joué en fait avec le gn 1 et
pour essayer de réguler et de contrôler
les flux migratoires
alors c'est d'autant plus cocasse que
l'italie se comporte de cette façon là
au moment où elle elle bénéficie du plan
de relance européen
la part du gâteau la plus importante
mais il faudra qu'elles choisissent où
elle est avec l'union européenne et
notamment avec la france et la grèce ou
face à à monsieur erdogan où elle est
avec
la turquie est de ce côté là j'ai de
grands doutes
alors on sait que d'autant plus
qu'aujourd'hui mais il paraît nécessaire
et à alésia les i je vous en prie oui
dites moi non je voulais ce qui est
regrettable dans ce qui se passe
actuellement avec une espèce de con
domaine de médium qu'on a
russo turque ans en libye c'est
l'absence de l'union africaine et
l'absence de l'union européenne nous
sommes aux portes de l'europe
la libye fait partie de notre dean
frontières de notre digue contre le
terrorisme au sahel bien sûr mais
surtout en libye et donc il est
inadmissible que l'union européenne ne
prenne pas une initiative forte pour
revenir dans le jeu en libye et
participer une médiation qui permettrait
à madame merkel et monsieur macron de
jouer un rôle est de permettre à
l'europe de jouer un rôle dans ce qui
est quand même son aire d'influencé
naturelle la méditerranée le maghreb et
le machrek la libye sont au coeur de la
sécurité européenne
au coeur du développement futur de
l'europe donc qu'attendons nous pour une
médiation forte et ne pas laisser les
turcs face aux russes parce que les
turcs et les russes n'ont rien à faire
en libye
alors justement vous parlez du rôle de
l'union africaine on se souvient qu'il
ya quelques semaines pays frontalier de
la libye l'egypte qui s'est dite prête à
intervenir au cas où justement où les
forces du gène a continué à progresser
sur le terrain est ce qu'aujourd'hui
voilà c'est c'est le seul rempart
possible dont vous êtes le rempart pour
pour la cyrénaïque pour les forces de la
laine et du maréchal haftar vous avez à
la fois d'abord l'armée du marshall
haftar qui est en capacité de résister à
une offensive elle a démontré récemment
avec deux opérations qui ont été faites
à l'ouest où ils ont détruit et la base
d'al watyah qui était tenue par le g n 1
et donc monsieur haftar la capacité de
résister mais il est évident que si
l'armée égyptienne rentrent dans la
danse
et si et si les russes
notamment au niveau aérien interviennent
il est évident que les turcs et le gène
ne pourront pas résister à cette
offensive faut pas oublier que dans
l'histoire au 19e siècle début du xxème
les égyptiens ont battu deux fois dans
deux grandes batailles les turcs alors
qu'ils étaient en infériorité numérique
jamais oublier cela
alors est-ce qu'on ira un conflit entre
l'egypte et la turquie
pour l'instant je ne crois pas pour
l'instant la parole est aux diplomates
et aux négociateurs
sachant les conséquences d'un conflit
pouvez vous imaginer que si l'egypte et
et la turquie s'affronter l'europe
resterait les bras croisés c'est
impossible
la france elle même sera obligée
d'intervenir il n'y a pas de cessez le
feu
officiellement donc les deux centrales
et les liens cessez le feu pour
l'instant sur les lignes de front entre
syrte syrte et joufra c'est la ligne
rouge que les égyptiens les russes
avaient indiqué à monsieur erdogan est
pour l'instant cette ligne n'a pas été
franchie donc pour l'instant il ya une
forme de cessez le feu
pour l'instant les problèmes vous savez
sont surtout du côté de tripoli un
puisque on parle de plus en plus le
soulèvement de population à cause des
problèmes d'électricité des problèmes
d'argent des problèmes de faim que
connaît la capitale libyenne
on parle de plus en plus de soulèvement
de populations civiles dans les
prochains jours deuxièmement vous avez
des affrontements entre milices
actuellement les milices de tripoli qui
ont toujours fait la loi à tripoli et
qu'ils détiennent en otage monsieur sa
rage ces milices en ce moment monsieur
bachagha fathi bachagha qu'est l'homme
fort de misrata est de tripoli
et quel ministre de l'intérieur essaye
de les mettre au pas d'autant plus que
de graves incidents se sont produits à
tripoli avec la population du fait de
l'arrivée de miliciens islamistes
syriens qui sont près de 13000
actuellement en libye et notamment à
tripoli et sur le front de l'ouest
ces gens là donc ont eu des accrochages
avec la population et donc ça pose de
plus en plus de problèmes
donc est ce que monsieur bachagha va
réussir à mettre au pas ces milices
qui sont liés à l'ancien ministre de la
défense monsieur oussama joue il dit qu
est le patron de l'ouest libyen
pour monsieur sa rage voilà donc c'est
dans les prochains jours nous allons et
éclairer sur cette situation là sachant
que de plus en plus monsieur sa rage qui
a toujours été le maillon faible de la
de la situation libyenne et du conflit
libyen est sur un siège éjectable
est-ce que les turcs mhr dogan suffiront
à le sauver je ne crois pas mais nous
serons fixés dans les prochains jours
alors la crise les viennent un dur
depuis la chute de saddam en remarquant
s'est fait en 2011
est ce qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas un
règlement politique que cela doit se
dérouler ce passé écoutez toutes les
tentatives politiques ont été faites
notamment par les émissaires de l'onu
depuis maintenant cinq ans cinq ans à
2015-2016 des accords de skhirat etc et
nous sommes en 2020 ils ont débouché sur
rien pour une raison très simple
madame c'est que tripoli à chaque fois
que monsieur sa rage a été une table de
négociation que ce soit paris à palerme
ou à doha à chaque fois ou à doit à
chaque fois quand il est rentré à
tripoli des milices l'on dit que s'il
signait c'était c'était sa fin donc à
chaque fois il est revenu sur sa parole
donc pour avoir un accord politique il
faut deux interlocuteurs dont kylie a
d'une part monsieur haftar et surtout le
président de l'assemblée nationale
libyenne
seule institution élue du pays monsieur
aguila salé et d'autre part en face il
n'y a rien pour l'instant alors est ce
que ce sera monsieur bachaga nous serons
bientôt fixés mais pour qui un accord
politique il faut être deux et donc on
est venu on en est venu à la situation
militaire
quand monsieur haftar a constaté que les
scellés les négociations politiques le
débouché sur rien et qu'on le balade est
depuis trois ans donc il a décidé de
prendre tripoli pour réunifier le pays
le pacifier de sécuriser son offensive
allez réussir puisqu'ils contrôlaient
déjà les deux tiers de la libye et elle
a échoué à cause de l'intervention de
monsieur erdogan qui a envoyé deux mille
officiers dessous
si les turcs et treize mille miliciens
syrien dont la plupart étaient des
membres de l'oit ou d'anciens membres de
dèche et qui avait participé au massacre
des kurdes en syrie
donc voilà une situation à laquelle nous
sommes confrontés qui est totalement
absurde et dans laquelle l'onu a une
part de responsabilité énorme merci
beaucoup
michel skalecki d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
ancien député européen et consultant sur
le moyen-orient